I feel like we've been hearing an awful
lot about the spring offensive is there
spring offensive Happening Now what is
going on the spring offensive we've
always talked about for both sides the
the challenge has been for Russia
they've almost gone across the style and
early and partly that appears to be out
of fear of what the Ukrainian spring
offensive might bring because that's
when the tanks are going to come in the
Russians have no answers to that and
what the Russians have been doing even
though the weather isn't suitable so
they've been confined to Road it's muddy
and really difficult they've thrown the
kitchen sink at trying to get some sort
of progress primarily along the Eastern
front and actually frankly they've made
very limited progress at all and almost
certainly they've run out of steam and
they've been redeploying their Russian
forces now away from that front line in
response now because they fully expect
in the coming weeks the Ukrainian is
going to start to push and they need to
be prepared for that if we look actually
what's happening on the ground at the
moment the Ukraine claims that they've
repelled 80 attacks over the last 24
hours there's been intense shelling all
over the place but it's not just the
military that die in this unfortunately
innocence Millions get caught up as well
reports of two civilians dying and seven
injured in Billy anchor and that was we
we had some video footage of that and it
was just devastating the effect on on
the village there there's also the
Russian military at the missile attacks
have decreased significantly over the
last few weeks probably because Russia
is running short of those missiles the
Ukrainian claimed that two missiles were
heading for Odessa down by you were shot
down overnight unfortunately one got
through at costyanka nivika here
um and that unfortunately hit a uh an
invincibility point now that is a
Ukrainian initiative that's designed to
provide protection for civilians
um it's got heat water and you know some
basic uh utensils unfortunately that hit
took three three women got killed and
looks like several more will have been
injured it's just a reminder isn't
actually said that the absolute
destruction to civilian life to life in
Ukraine yeah you know as everyone knowed
it
um I'm interested to talk about the
Wagner group because it feels like this
is a kind of fascinating sort of
underbelly I guess to the war because
just right who's this guy what's going
on you have guinea pig goes in who's the
head of the funk group he was a
convicted thief and he's now become the
head of our group a bunch of mercenaries
and does a lot of dirty work around the
world uh on behalf of President Putin if
you recall that um the fighting Uh
Russian army wasn't doing very well
particularly in the back mutes area they
brought in these guys and they have made
progress albeit slow because they were
making progress his influence started to
rise he was very critical of the Russian
leadership particularly the Army and all
of a sudden President Putin started to
feel threatened he denied him access to
the prisons where he was getting
convicts his recruits and he also denied
him some ammunition now of course they
were at the front line of back moods
ammunition is essential so all of a
sudden his language has definitely
softened towards the Kremlin but at a
recent long interview that he did it's
evident he's not a political monster
he's a military monster and in this
interview he said very publicly he goes
out on their state television the
fighting in Ukraine um that was actually
against Ukrainian soldiers nothing to do
with NATO he said that they've not
encountered any Nazis in bass at all and
he also said that the new Russian
borders need to be defined pretty
quickly because the Russian forces were
running out of steam all those messages
run completely counter to the Putin's
now we always wonder who speaks truth to
power in Putin's Russia he's not likely
candidates do it but it'd be really
interesting to see how this messaging
docks and you do often see don't you the
kind of military leaders
perhaps becoming playing a role in the
downfall of some of the leaders too I
mean obviously we maybe that's well it's
particularly interesting here because
what are his agenda he's a he's a
convicted uh he's a convict and actually
he deploys all over the world and
actually he will have his own business
interests that have nothing to do with
Russia in this conflict fascinating to
see the role of private military
organizations which are illegal in
Russia being funded by Russia in the war
in Ukraine that's really interesting
um what's the latest when it comes to uh
weapons quickly because there's been a
lot of talk about what what we're giving
what we should be doing well there's a
lot of talk no the other day we're
giving challenge two tanks they use a
depleted uranium round because it's very
good at getting through armor President
Putin's turn around and said that that
is now it's nuclear because it's you
uranium therefore that that will trigger
a nuclear war and let's be clear that
the uranium-235 which is the main
element of nuclear weapons and nuclear
power stations highly radioactive a
piece of uranium is what's left when you
finish that it's not highly Radioactive
It's got Alpha articles which can't even
get through your skin it's only
dangerous if you ingest it or or or
breathe it in and even then it's because
it's poisonous not because of the
radiation at all what's interesting
particularly is that Russia actually
uses depleted uranium in some of their
weapons as well so this is nothing more
than Putin's rhetoric again and
scaremonger